Being a teen can be an amazing time of discovery,
learning, and friendship, but it’s also
a time of rapid change, and emotional highs
and lows where things can feel really ‘tough’.
So, what’s going on in our brains and bodies
that makes us feel this way? Why is being
a teen so hard?
We’re often told that the most important
years of brain development are between 0-5,
although recent research has found adolescent
development to be equally important. During
childhood, our brains continually grow, generating
grey matter until they reach their maximum
size, which for girls is around age 12 and
boys around age 14. But even after this, the
brain works to become more efficient by cutting
away unused grey matter that isn’t ‘exercised’
by experience, and at the same time increasing
myelin - fatty tissue that insulates brain
pathways.
Puberty begins in the hypothalamus, where
a protein called kisspeptin is produced, triggering
the pituitary gland to unleash the hormones
testosterone, estrogen and progesterone. These
activate the ovaries and testes, but also
cause you to seek emotionally charged experiences
- whether it’s a movie to make you sob,
or driving 180 km/h down the freeway. It causes
your response to emotionally loaded images
or sounds to be more intense, which is why
listening to One Direction may produce large
bouts of the feels.
The area of the brain responsible for planning
ahead and assessing risk is still immature
in teenagers. Which is why teens are more
likely to participate in high risk behaviour
like unprotected sex and drinking and driving.
Interestingly, in a simulated driving experience,
adults and teens took the same amount of driving
risks while alone; however, when surrounded
by an audience of friends, teens took significantly
more risks while adults were unaffected. What’s
the benefit of this behaviour? Peer acceptance.
In a study where teens were asked to rank
music clips with and without knowing what
their peers picked, their choices changed.
Unlike small children and adults, feeling
socially isolated as a teen creates feelings
of intense unworthiness. This along with our
biology can contribute to teens prioritizing
friends over even family. As social animals,
stepping outside the safety of our family
creates genetically diverse populations, diminishing
the likliness of inbreeding. In fact, teens
have heightened social abilities like processing
and evaluating facial expressions better than
other age groups, allowing teens to be extremely
cognisant of friends joy, sadness, or stress.
Speaking of stress, the hormone released in
stressful situations to help sooth the
brain cells of children and adults has the
opposite impact on teens, causing an increase
in anxiety. Pair that with a change in circadian
rhythms making you to want to wake three to
four hours later than adults, it’s no wonder
some people describe teens as emotionally
‘moody’.
On the other hand, teens are very physically
healthy. The immune system is highly functioning,
teens have increased tolerance to temperature
changes and a high resistance to cancer. But
despite physical fitness, records show that
death rates increase by 200-300% after childhood
due to motor vehicle accidents, homicide and
suicide. Several mental illnesses emerge,
during adolescence such as anxiety, depression
and eating disorders. Scientists believe that
the many changes in white matter, grey matter,
and connections in the brain may be to blame,
with an increased risk of errors during this
time.
But with a greater number of synaptic connections,
and increased plasticity, the teenage brain
is primed to learn quickly and memorize content
fast. Unlike an older brain, rooted in what
it knows, teens can respond easily to their
environment and make incredible strides in
communication and socialization. Not to mention
being passionate is incredibly valuable and
taking risks is often what is needed to make
changes in your life and the lives of others
- being a teen can be tough, but it can also
be amazing.
If you want to know why teens are the biggest
super fans and become obsessed with their
favourite bands or shows, check out our latest
AsapTHOUGHT on the Science of Fandom. Links
in the description! And subscribe for more weekly science videos.